what's going on everybody welcome to
another Python series this series is
going to be concerning my sequel with
Python so if you're only after simple
storage and retrieval and you want just
the most basic solution for that yet you
still want to use an SQL database then
you might be interested more so in my
SQLite series so SQLite as its name
suggests is a lightweight SQL solution
that is really easily used with Python
and so I will put the links of those
three videos in the description
basically the first one setting up the
database second one is storing data and
the third one is retrieving data now
historically I've avoided doing a full
my sequel tutorial mostly because like
Windows users are going to tend to have
issues installing and setting up an SQL
server to run on their computer and it
just it just would have been a mess
right so you got a like set it up and
open up the right ports it's in the
correct information to the ninth ward of
the interplanetary xenon space cake
Victor Charlie alpha and you know what
at that point you know people just kind
of throw in the towel
so we wouldn't really get very far
probably have really bad retention
because it's just kind of tough so I did
just recently show you guys that Python
anywhere website which is here and I
thought you know what this would be a
good place to do SQL plus Python so
anybody that doesn't want to have to
deal with installing my sequel or my
sequel post Python rather so anybody
there was one I deal with you know
installing and setting up a my sequel
server maybe run their computer if they
don't already have like a shared hosting
plan somewhere or even VPS and whatnot
that they could still follow along so
even noobs because most of my tutorials
I try to make them to the point where if
you're brand new you can still follow
along so really this just makes the
perfect solution because everyone in it
will be able to follow along identically
with me if they want to and everyone is
on the same platform so that makes it
just super easy so setting up an account
on here is real quick and easy
if you don't have an account already you
probably rive at a page like this it's
completely free to make an account you
just don't get a lot of processing but
we'll structure the tutorial so you
won't exceed that processing anyways so
you can make an account just click here
and it's very sincere and it's a little
statement here you can create a beginner
account and literally you fill this out
hit this register you're ready to go so
I'm going to go ahead and log in now to
my account which just so happens to be
beginner account so I'll log into that
apparently that was dashboard I don't
know why it sent me back to that page
anyway so when you log in you should see
something like this and it just so
happens that they've actually already
got my sequel installed and ready to go
if you decided to not follow my my
advice and just follow us here you can
run a sudo apt-get install my sequel -
server sudo apt-get install Python - my
sequel DB then do a my seat or go into
your you know my sequel like with bash
my sequel - you root - P get it just
whatever it takes for you to get into
that basically my sequel line here well
we can't I can't show you just yet but
I'll show you guys in a second and then
you just you know write create database
test DB or whatever you want to make and
you're the name of your database and
then you'll be able to follow along with
us and that should be really it if you
want to cheat so anyways with that I'm
gonna let that you guys that want to
blaze your own path will continue
blazing your own path so anyway if now
that you've got an account whenever you
come here what we want to do is yeah we
want to make a database here so and then
also keep this in mind whenever you're
connecting to a database like say you
did have a local database a lot of times
you can just say localhost is where you
want to connect as long as the files are
on the same server but you can't do that
here so this will take the place of
localhost and then your username is the
same username you're using and then
database password suggested that you
don't use the same password
account name because of right here it's
going to any any like text or any Python
applications you write that database
password is going to be visible
invisible so with that I'm going to go
ahead and make my password um
cookies since y'all are going to see it
anyways
so set database password awesome so now
we've got the first database here and
you can see the name of the database as
always you get set up with a default
database or a database called default
but every database you ever make like if
you make another database like I'll make
a database called tutorial and you
create that database you'll see that it
always starts with beginner account
dollar son and then the name of that
database so that's that now you've got
the database setup announced learn to
kind of communicate with it so
eventually yeah you want to communicate
with it via a Python script but also you
want to know how to communicate with it
by hand basically so you can later
communicate via SSH and then later
communicate via SSH by your program so
it does become useful to be able to do
this in plus if you want to run
especially when it comes to creating
tables that sometimes it's just quicker
by hand to make it by hand then to code
a program that makes the table if it's a
new thing anyways if you're going to be
making a lot of new tables and you might
as well make a program to do it but
anyway and then also when it comes to
like deleting or getting rid of maybe
corrupt data you usually do that by hand
so anyway um it's good to know how to do
it so what we're going to do is pop over
to consoles now they're nice and they
give us a my sequel console so you can
just click on this and you start already
in the my sequel console as soon as it
loads and so yeah so you're ready to
give my sequel queries but not everybody
is going to have it that way and if you
ever move on past maybe hosting here you
have another hosting provider you pry
are going to get that you're just gonna
have a bash line when you connect by SSH
it's going to look more like this so how
you get to that my sequel first of all
you better have my sequel installed and
a database and everything but here what
you're going to do is call my C
cool and then we're going to - you and
then you put in your username in my case
it's beginner I was a beginner user
being in our account already forgot let
me go okay look I just made it
it's beginner at count so it gets right
good job we get our account and then - H
and so user is just your username right
and then - H will be where you're
connecting so a lot of times it would be
localhost but in our case we can't do
that so it's my sequel dot server and @p
and now you're going to need to put in
the password this is the password your
database password right so in my case it
was cookies whatever yours is can be
whatever I highly suggest cookies it's a
great password I'm just kidding I don't
anyway so now we're in the database so
the first thing that you'll be able to
do and the only thing that we can do so
far since pretty much all we have is a
database is run a command called show
databases
don't forget your semicolons otherwise
it's going to do this to you and you're
going to like I forgot my semicolon
anyway so now what it's going to do is
is print out it's a best attempt at a
GUI and it prints out you know we've got
information information schema then
we've got the default table or I mean a
default database not a table and then
we've got the one that we made now it's
not really necessary you don't have to
do your commands in all caps but all
generally especially in code it makes it
really helpful to anybody reading it to
know what's like a table name and what's
an actual sequel command so you've got
all kinds of stuff like oops I thought I
hit the caps select and insert and
delete and all this kind of stuff an
update not that update so you put in all
caps but you don't have to but just
helps for your purposes and debugging
and also reading your own old scripts
maybe and then also if you're
collaborating with people it's just nice
another useful query to have it you can
run it pretty much whenever is show
process list and what this is going to
do is show you all the processes that
are occurring right now and so if you
ever have like a process that you find
yourself with my sequel is use
up a hundred percent of your CPU and you
want to know what the heck is going on
you can do this and see what kind of
processes are still running and then you
can shut them down
by their little ID right here so you can
kill the process I'll probably show you
guys that later but anyway just that's
where you can start whenever if you if
you do find yourself at 100% you don't
know why so anyway those are the basic
topics now in the next video I'm going
to be talking about setting up a new
table via you know the same rule command
line here and then a little bit of
inserting data into those tables and
then probably in the next video after
that manipulating that data a little bit
just and then also just some pro tips
right I'm not a pro but these are other
people's pro tips so anyway stay tuned
for those videos as always thanks for
watching thanks for the support in the
subscriptions and until next time